Donald Trump held another series of rallies
yesterday.
And at this sort of late stage in the election,
with just five days remaining and nearly 80
million votes already cast.
The rallies are becoming dramatically more
unhinged.
You can track it on a day to day basis.
Now, part of it may be exhaustion on Donald
Trump's behalf.
Part of it may be desperation.
But yesterday was wacky and out there.
Now, first of all, a really strange moment
in Arizona.
Trump brought out Congressman Kevin McCarthy,
who I guess wants to be speaker of the House
if Republicans take the House next week, which
they won't.
Republicans are not taking the House next
week.
And he said he wouldn't bang Nancy Pelosi
with the gavel.
A bizarre moment it'll be before we swear
in the president again.
But the reason why I want you to come.
I want you to watch Nancy Pelosi hand me that
gavel.
And I promise you this, I won't paint her
with it, but I'll bang the end to the socialism
and yes, to America.
Really strange stuff there.
And Trump now is regularly complaining about
the weather and the temperature at his rallies.
It's either too cold or too hot or too windy.
Arizona, I guess, was too hot for him.
And I'm sitting in the hottest sun I've ever
felt.
This is hot.
My last stop.
Also in your great state.
It had a different problem, the sun was hot.
I've never seen wind like that.
It's lucky I don't need Teleprompter's like
sleepy Joe.
Crazy Teleprompter's were falling down.
They were going all over the place.
I was getting a headache.
I'm trying to look, but I have a good memory.
I remember things.
Now, he said he doesn't need a teleprompter
while using a teleprompter.
In that clip.
But is anybody else sick of the whining?
This is the wideness President.
I can remember Leslie Stall wasn't fair and
Twitter is not fair and the fake news isn't
fair and it's too cold.
And now it's too hard and it's too windy and
it's too sunny and I'm too sweaty.
This is the most privileged man in America.
And he thinks he's the biggest victim.
He can't stop complaining.
In this next clip, Trump actually doesn't
know what citizen this is.
This is the best.
Trump doesn't know what city he's in.
And even though he criticizes Biden for using
a prompter, he struggles to read the name
of the city.
He's in off of the prompter because it's Windy
City.
And from Phenix to right here in Bullhead.
That sector is moving so much.
Hey, look, I'm trying to go up and is my head
moving up and down like this?
You did a great job of anchoring these things.
Fell is a great job.
Yet.
Trump, who has been accusing his opponent
of cognitive decline, doesn't know what city
he's in unless he reads it off a prompter,
which he criticizes Joe Biden for using.
And Trump then claims this is now in Bullhead
City, Arizona.
Trump still ridiculing masks as we have more
than 200 33000 Corona virus deaths.
Was sleepy Joe, there'd be no graduations,
no weddings, no Thanksgiving, they're already
talking about no Thanksgiving.
And in California you have a special mass.
You can not under any circumstances take it
off.
You have to eat through.
The mascot's in.
Right.
Right, Charlie hits.
It's a very complex mechanism.
And they don't realize as germs, they go through
it like that and they look at you with that
contraption and they say, that's it, easy
when I go right through with the flu.
Now, how about California, though, where you're
supposed to eat with a mass caretaker?
OK.
So then the audio problem started with insane
wind and people on stage behind Trump pulling
their masks off.
Just everything going wrong with the states
by.
These guys, yeah, that's right, baby.
Now, it's probably a rhino is operating, they're
having a bad day today.
They're having a bad day, but we're having
a good day.
Dijo these rallies have become parodies of
themselves, truly.
And I the audio issues continue.
This next video, I don't know why this next
one I found so funny.
I was crying from laughter last night to the
West.
I was preparing this clip to the point where
my girlfriend came up to my office and started
filming me, watching this clip and laughing
hysterically.
I don't know why I find this so funny, but
I do know, Runnable, these people know what
the hell they're doing.
Let me recover my ears for once.
Whoever did this microphone don't pay these
people.
There's also something I mean, it's horrible,
but it's also, in a way, very trumpy in to
immediately start attacking workers saying
they don't know what the hell they're doing.
As far as audio equipment is concerned, one
audio text sent me a message on Twitter saying
I'm an audio tech.
The whoever is working the audio is really
doing God's work by interfering with Donald
Trump's speech.
And then under the category of complete and
total lies, just complete lies that make no
sense.
Donald Trump claims that Joe Biden wants to
ban weddings, graduations and even Thanksgiving.
We're sleepy, John.
There'd be no graduations, no weddings, no
Thanksgiving, they're already talking about
no Thanksgiving.
And in California, you have a special mass.
You can not under any circumstances, take
it off.
You have to eat through the mascot's.
Do you think anybody really believes that
or are even his supporters seeing it as sort
of performance?
Theater meant just to get a reaction.
And then at the earlier rally, Trump complained,
as I mentioned, not about the heat, but about
the wind.
You know, it's windy as hell out here.
You know, I said, is it windy?
Should I bring that hat?
Because I don't love my arm flopping around
one thing.
At least they figured out after three years
that it is mine.
If it was it, I would have found out about
it today.
Just stay home.
Maybe, like, don't do the rallies if it's
either too windy or too hot or too cold or
too sunny or too dark.
Just stay home and don't do it, because quite
frankly, all you're really doing is spreading
corona virus and in some cases giving old
folks hypothermia.
And these are all Trump voters anyway.
You're not convincing anybody with these rallies?
I would say just stay home the next five days.
He doesn't plan to, though.
That's for sure.
President Donald Trump's son in law and senior
adviser Jared Kushner bragged in April as
the country was reopening under Donald Trump's
direction about how Donald Trump took control
back from the doctors.
Understand what this means.
Here is Jared Kushner bragging to Bob Woodward,
apparently having ill advised conversations
with Bob Woodward runs in the Trump family.
Here is Jared Kushner bragging about this.
The last thing was kind of doing the guidelines,
which was interesting.
And that, in my mind was almost like it was
almost like Trump getting the country back
from the doctor straight in the sense that
what he now did was, you know, he's going
to only the open up.
There were three phases.
There's the panic phase, the pain phase and
then the comeback phase.
That doesn't mean there's not still a lot
of pain and there won't be pain for a while.
But that basically was we've now put out rules
to get back to work.
Trump's now back in charge.
It's not the doctors they've got us.
We have to negotiate a settlement, taking
the country back from the doctors during a
global pandemic.
We need the doctors.
Imagine saying we've got to take the airplanes
back from the pilots.
All of these checklists and fuel calculations
and talking about what do we do if we have
to do an emergency?
We got to take control back from these pilots,
will cut down the turnaround time by 30 minutes
each way, and we'll be able to fly an additional
flight every single day.
That's essentially what they're saying here.
Let's take the clearing of toilet backups
back from the plumbers, my friends.
It's time to get these overconfident idiot
plumbers out of here.
That's a phrase Jared Kushner will use in
this next clip.
Remember when they said, what was it?
We need a businessman running the country
like a business?
Well, he saw himself as negotiating with doctors
to get more deaths in exchange for some businesses
opening.
Take a listen.
The most dangerous people around the president
are overconfident idiots.
Right.
Because that has a way sometimes of getting
past his defense mechanism.
Because if you're overconfident, then sometimes,
you know, on a topic where he doesn't have
other people around to kind of validate it,
then he can sometimes say, OK, let's go with
that.
So that's kind of I think if you look at the
evolution of time, we've gotten rid of a lot
of the overconfident idiots.
And now he's got a lot more thoughtful people
who kind of know their place and know what
to do.
The most dangerous people around Trump are
overconfident idiots like Jared, not like
the doctors.
Instead, they want people who know their place,
like, for example, doctors who will let Trump
do whatever he wants.
People like Scott Atlas, who is actually the
epitome of an overconfident idiot, a neuro
radiologist who was brought in to deal with
an infectious disease.
But Scott Atlas knows his place.
Very revealing comments from Jared Kushner.
And then this next one is really just stunning.
It's Kushner confirming exactly what I've
been saying for years about both Donald Trump
and his followers.
It's not about issues.
It's not about policy.
It's about attitude.
It's about pissing people off.
And Kushner says it.
Listen to this.
And so, you know, you look at like the Republican
Party platform.
It's a document meant like piss people off,
basically, because it's done by activists.
Yeah.
So you have a disproportionality between what
issues people are vocal on and.
And what the people, the voters really care
about and what Trump's been able to do, as
I say, he's basically get a hostile takeover
of the Republican Party.
And I don't think it's even as much about
the issue as I think it's about the attitude.
Just Jared Kushner completely laying bare
every one of our worst suspicions about these
people.
And it's been obvious for a long time that
this had happened.
But to hear them say it's so overtly is chilling.
Trump claims to be a great businessman, Jared
Kushner, a great businessman.
And yet they don't realize that the way to
get the economy back is not to reopen prematurely.
It was always to deal with the pandemic that
would naturally fix the economy.
They've never understood it.
And so it just goes on and on.
And now Trump is endlessly repeating, oh,
Biden wants to lock everything down fout.
She wants to lock everything down, everyone.
But Trump wants to take away your freedoms.
But the goal isn't to lock down and restrict
freedoms.
It's let's unite against a common enemy and
deal with the pandemic to save both American
lives and to save the economy in the long
term.
The economy would naturally recover with the
pandemic under control.
And instead, this administration has said,
let's get the doctors out of here.
Let's force openings, because the focus was,
I guess, short term gains, even though I believe
it has completely backfired.
Let's see if the election results bear that
out.
And, you know, at the tail end of this, if
you open too early, you're almost guaranteeing
another shutdown.
And even if it's not an official shutdown,
it's people who are going to stay home here
in Massachusetts as cases have gone from 150
a day to three hundred, six hundred, twelve
hundred.
And now even more things are remaining open
because it doesn't seem there's any political
willingness to start shutting things down.
But people are staying home more and more
because they see the numbers and that's the
reality.
You can't short change actually dealing with
the problem and focusing only on haphazardly
fixing the symptoms.
But it just doesn't work and it's not work.
Then we're seeing it now.
We'll continue discussing this on the show's
Instagram at David Pakman show.
And if you're on Instagram, you might as well
find me on Instagram at David Dot.